so who's my guest this week it's the
former senior white house advisor fiona
hill
it was one of the most compelling
appearances during the trump impeachment
hearings blunt composed and incredibly
distinctive with her strong northern
english accent
president trump's top russia expert was
devastating in her assessment of policy
and culture in trump's white house
her warning about putin's danger to the
west and how american ideals that were
so appealing to her were under threat
putin is always looking out to see if
there is any hint that we will not
follow through on promises that we have
made because he will always follow
through on a threat
fiona hill's journey from a poor english
mining town to working for three
presidents in washington is documented
in her book there is nothing for you
here
where she takes her story of social
mobility and opportunity and argues that
class and racial barriers are still
holding too many back here's a bit of
what's coming up
and imagine if trump had actually
succeeded on january 6 and the members
of the january 6 committee in the us
congress
are pretty convinced that we were very
close to him succeeding had not vice
president pence
uh basically refused to block the
transfer of executive power i mean we'd
be in a totally different place i mean
vladimir putin would have probably just
you know driven right into ukraine
himself
fiona thank you so much for coming to
talk to us thanks so much really
interesting to hear what you have to say
especially because for a lot of people
they wouldn't have heard of you before
that first impeachment inquiry in which
you appeared
and i wonder for you
do you replay that moment do you think
about it and what do you think about i
actually don't i mean maybe that sounds
a little bit strange but it was kind of
it's one of those things where you're so
focused in the moment
that when you come out again it's almost
like it didn't happen because it was
such an intense period of concentration
a lot of effort leading up to it
and then
you know the kind of aftermath was sort
of moving on to the next thing because
so much happened as a consequence of
that that i hadn't anticipated that i i
find it very kind of hard looking back
to it i find it fascinating in your book
you talk about this being prepared for
the room that it was going to be quite
cold
and also how you looked as a woman all
these things had to be factored in when
i'm sure you just wanted to give the
information exactly i mean i didn't know
i'd have to think about this i mean
literally one of the very first
questions was we're gonna have to figure
out what you're going to wear i thought
what and i said well does that happen to
men and they said well not so much but
the point is that as a woman you know
people are already wondering who you are
and they literally said to me you don't
want to be a distraction from the truth
and the reason i wanted to put this in
the book is that look most times when
men write a book nobody asks them about
how it is to be a man nobody even kind
of thinks about what it is that they
were wearing or you know in a particular
setting and you know they just go there
and they you know do their job i mean
yes if you're going to appear on
television everybody now these days with
high definition tv has to have you know
some makeup on their head and you know
cut otherwise they look like they've
died and it'd be kind of just the whole
bright lights effect but for something
as serious and consequential as a as a
testimony i thought the whole fact that
it was there was focus on how i would
look as part of my presenting myself so
that people would listen to my answers
and just for telling the truth i mean
that really hit me and thought about you
know what a difference it really is to
be a woman in these kinds of settings
and what did you do how did you make
sure you were listening to in terms of
how you looked and then how did you feel
did you have to wear extra layers did
you have to take the advice i did and i
had a really good um pr person a woman
that i've mentioned in the book called
molly levinson who you know did this for
a living and had been in you know the
broadcast media as well as a producer
and but who had worked with uh people in
these kinds of settings for a long
period of time and you know she
literally went through my wardrobe she
said you know you have to look a
particular look she said that will be
picked up by the washington post style
section while that look was
when we were picked up by the washington
star section which i was pretty
incredulous about the beginning they
said we were reassuringly dull
so that was what she was looking for
because i was basically testifying with
another person david holmes from the um
us embassy in kiev did he look
reassuring well i thought he looked
quite smart actually but um
the whole view was you know reassuringly
dull bureaucrat luck there was a fiona
hill fan club that sort of sprung up
online actually from from across the
spectrum in some ways as people heard
what you had to say and stayed a lot of
people talking about how focused you
stayed on the facts and some of those
almost we'll get to through your
expertise but
did you feel it was a good use of your
time or do you feel it was a waste of
your time because ultimately it didn't
work i had john bolton on the former
national security adviser to trump very
recently and he didn't testify because
he thought it would be a waste of time
it depends on what your perspective is
about you know waste of time a good use
of time
in the united states there is still this
concept of civics education where people
fully understand how their government
works
um and especially important in something
like a representative democracy a
liberal democracy where you know you was
the regular person wants to feel that
your public servants your members of
congress or members of parliament are
actually taking your interest into
consideration and you know listening to
you
and understanding that there are checks
and balances on executive power
particularly on abuses of power which
this was you know clearly the case and
you know this whole definition of crimes
and misdemeanors and how does this
process play out it was an exercise in
liberal democracy it's the checks and
the bonds the oversight of congress it
ultimately didn't work yeah but it
showed people that the system was there
and that everybody got to hear the truth
and i think a lot of people came away
from that realizing that it was wrong
for basically donald trump to ask
vladimir zelinski the president of
ukraine for a personal favor now the
political outcome of this the parties
and political outcome of this was of
course that there was no censure even um
of uh trump he didn't get any kind of
penalty just it wasn't even a wrap on
the knuckles of the wrist you know from
any perspective and as ambassador bolton
john bolton said
well it could seem to be a waste of time
if anybody was really expecting there to
be some massive outcome for trump
himself i think it actually also
emboldened him to go on to the next
thing that he got impeached twice more
were there any negative outcomes for for
you being out there and effectively
going viral oh there was a lot i mean
there was all kinds of misogyny and
sexism and threats and you know threats
of bodily harm and you know kind of all
kinds of how did they come to you mostly
through the internet so i just stopped
engaging i mean my sister who was
constantly monitoring twitter and
facebook and things would you know give
me warnings and she would get in touch
with the platforms to try to get people
to take down some of the you know most
outrageous things i'd get phone calls
letters emails but actually i have to
say that it was a smaller percentage
than what was really an overwhelming
i would say positive response in terms
of just thank you for telling the truth
and again everybody can tell the truth
so i didn't think it was that
extraordinary and you know again there
was a lot of other people who did
testify my colleagues i mean that people
have got to know as well
and
you know i really took away from that
that there was
a kind of a great thirst for people just
standing up there and telling things
like they are talking about what you
know and your expertise of course it's
russia and it's it's hugely in demand
right now
and i wanted to talk about ukraine from
the perspective of of all you have
looked at and and all you're looking at
right now do you think the conflict the
war was inevitable i don't actually i
think there's all kinds of junks along
the way in everything where you know
things can take a different path i think
that what happened in terms of the
decision making of vladimir putin is he
thought you know there was a number of
things going on first of all he thought
the west had lost the plot that we
become very weak and distracted that
indeed we all be doing is engaging with
partisan and fights with each other
identity politics you know you name it
but he saw over a long period of time
an inability for the west to stand up to
its own values and its own principles
particularly when it came to pressure on
other countries so ukraine was in the
crosshairs
you know going back to in fact the early
2000s and even back into the 1990s and
we didn't really do anything same when
georgia was invaded
back in 2008 each time we'd find an
excuse and not really take very strong
measures
i also think that two years of kovitch
had an impact
you know like the rest of us he was kind
of sitting down
you know hunkered down
excluding you know people from coming
close to him not wanting to get sick
but he also
became more and more isolated we could
see from the people who used to get
access to him so he starts to be
basically shrunk down in his terms of
advice to a smaller and smaller group of
people and clearly he convinced himself
that he could get away with this and
that there would be no backlash either
in ukraine or anywhere else in the world
but do you think i mean for instance
you've mentioned a whole series of
events leading up to this but for
instance there are some now saying that
uh the the presidency of trump and the
attack on january the sixth on the
capital
was a moment a particular moment did you
buy into that
from putin's point of view exactly i
mean look the united states looks like
it was finished
and imagine if trump had actually
succeeded on january 6 and the members
of the january 6 committee uh in the us
congress
are pretty convinced that we were very
close to him succeeding had not vice
president pence
uh basically refused to block the
transfer of executive power and uh had
agreed in fact to just go ahead uh
pushed ahead rather than agreed to it i
mean disagreed with what trump was
asking him to do and you know basically
um certified the uh electoral votes i
mean we'd be in a totally different
place i mean vladimir putin would have
probably just you know driven right into
ukraine himself because he then would
have seen the united states as
completely finished from a leadership
perspective because we would be no
different from any other country in the
world that had just had a coup
how concerned are you about nuclear
conflict at this moment in time well i'm
very concerned about some one-sided
action on the part of putin and i think
it's very important for all of us to
put that into a context and not be
intimidated because that's exactly what
he wants to do putin wants to take us
all back to the 1980s and the euro
missile crisis and more scares or back
to the days of the cuban missile crisis
so everyone's thinking they've got a
duck and cover again putin is kind of a
free agent maverick when it comes to
this he's sort of in a way revived the
soviet era instruments of nuclear
missiles and biological and chemical
weapons he's already used chemical
weapons with novichok and polonium i
mean here in the united kingdom in
assassination attempts for example
during the syrian war after the russians
intervene there was lots of chemical you
know weapons attacks lots of threats of
all kinds of things going and just by
rhetorically putting out there the
prospect that he might use a nuclear
weapon talking about the chances that he
might use a tactical battlefield nuclear
weapon he's trying to get us all scared
so that we back off and then basically
agree to surrender ukraine or whatever
else it is that he but
do you not believe it then i suppose i
believe that he's thinking about doing
it but i think that what we need to do
is to push back against that because we
need to understand why he's doing it
he's doing it because he feels on the
back foot right now he hasn't been able
to press forward with the aims in the
way that he wanted them politically and
then militarily and he's doing it
because he figures we're going to get
scared so how do you do this with him i
mean you talk as if right we need to
understand him you're giving some of the
expertise that you've got the
intelligence as well that you will have
heard about but how do you negotiate
with putin well what you have to do is
get a full court press on him here
because putin wants this all to be about
just his discussions with biden or just
his discussions with you know kind of
the west because again
ukraine is one of the objects here and
the other object is rolling back nato
and getting rid of the united states in
european affairs but what he's doing has
global consequences and we need china we
need india we need you know other
countries to push back japan and south
korea get it and i mean they've been
very much supported but we need to get
more than that we need to be able to
show the rest of the world that this has
global consequences and this isn't just
an east-west spot but it's just not
possible to keep moving forward denying
components to the russian military for
the war not just giving you know more
weapons to ukraine
problems of accessing the funding you
know basically making
you know heading heading him off at
every pass but diplomatically if he's
hearing it from not just the nato
countries not just the west not just the
sort of usual suspects but quietly from
others saying look you know what you're
doing here is having terrible
consequences for us as well famine in
africa you know kind of really putting
on edge
security elsewhere in the world
that's when we might have a chance of
pushing this in a different direction i
mean i suppose what you're talking about
there is leadership and who's going to
be doing that and if they're doing that
and you have worked for three presidents
but only known uh by one
as russia [ __ ] were you actually known
as that apparently i mean i didn't know
that in real time i learned that later
from an american journalist who was
doing some interviews um for a piece
afterwards and this was how he was not
surprised
by donald trump well by some of the
people around him i don't know
he himself ever said that i don't think
so i think that gives a window though
into the the climate within which you
were working especially as an expert on
russia and as a woman yeah very much so
it's just that kind of casual misogyny
you know who does she think she is that
woman who works on russia and it's kind
of obvious i mean i i wasn't the
slightest bit surprised when i heard
that i mean i was a bit surprised that i
thought the particular person was a
tribute to you i hadn't even noticed who
i was i thought oh well i guess they did
know who i was i i wonder because of
what you're saying here were you
actually listened to by donald trump
i don't think he listened to anybody but
apart from you know people who we saw as
peers i mean that's why you know we saw
in weirdness in real time of him you
know with putin talking about putin
being strong and powerful he was
listening to putin over his intelligence
chiefs for example at the
summit at helsinki in that dreadful
press conferences we knew that he
listened to people on fox news
and on other you know media outlets
many of the people you know including
ambassador bolton um and others would
try to get on the sunday shows because
they knew that he would be watching they
were more likely to have him listen to
them if they were on the tv screen then
um he would listen if he was in the oval
office and there's all that kind of
bizarre you know creativity that had to
go on to get his attention because if he
went in and you sat down you were just
his stuff
so he basically projected but that
sounds like it's men and women or would
you say it was worse i think it was
worse for women but not all women i mean
there were some women that he respected
and listened to like kellyanne conway
and his daughter ivanka trump but once a
person started working for him no matter
what they had been before that status
disappeared i mean he projected onto the
government the same style i presume that
he had in his private business when it
was you know the trump family
enterprises and that everyone was then
the staff so why would you listen to
them i mean in that context information
and um recommendations and direction
trickled down from him not up you know
if you're an eponymous family firm
that's your brand your firm you just
tell other people you know what to do in
the case you us government they're
supposed to be much more you know
advisers are supposed to be advised the
national security advisor knows their
stuff they're supposed to be able to
have a say in this they're coordinating
all the way across the government and as
far as trump was concerned we were all
some version of staff when he you know
when if you were called secretary of
state as secretary of defense you were
just a glorified secretary if you were a
woman you were pretty likely to be a
regular secretary
i mean how did you take this in your
stride did it get to you i know you've
been on the women's march and then you
accepted this job because you wanted to
contribute you know and put something
back and help yeah i mean i wasn't
deluded in that sense i mean what i
think really did get to me was just the
dirty politics
because again i'm not a partisan person
i'm politically engaged politically
active but i'm not political i've never
been on a political campaign and just
this you know game of thrones you know
kind of people stabbing each other in
the back i mean yeah it happens in every
political system but there's just the
dirty corruption behind the scenes as
well
i did really genuinely think that people
would understand on the national
security front that you know you needed
to check all of that when it came to
certain issues really critical issues
where american lives were at stake or
the whole stability of the globe let's
put it that way the people would check
themselves but you have a shock to find
they didn't and that's what got to me
well you also said that you know being
groped in the 70s and 80s working in a
golf club
had been preparation good preparation
yeah i mean i would have preferred not
to have that and actually i don't know
it'd just be very clear nobody did that
to me in the white house but you know
just remember the point of the
experience as a context is an
extraordinary
extraordinary piece of help almost that
you you cite it when working in this
yeah i mean that was kind of the weird
thing if you know growing up as a you
know a girl in you know 1970s 1980s
britain you know kind of dominated by
benny hill and you know raunchy
postcards seaside and just all the
things that kind of come without nobody
even thinks about you think it's very
funny what if you're a young girl it's
actually not very funny but you you know
you just learn to have to laugh about it
this is so you know pre me too that you
know it seems like a another world and
yet we still get all of that misogyny
and sexism there was you know a dress
code inside of the white house um it was
you know kind of very much you know fox
news if anyone's seen the film bombshell
i mean i thought that was actually it
would have been good preparation for
watching before i kind of went in there
you know and i was always aware that i
had to you know change the way i dress
somewhat just so i blend in so that
nobody would you know pay too much
attention and one of the you know the
funniest episodes uh came when you know
he thought i was a secretary and i was
told by a senior colleague
you know look just don't worry about
that you know he'll forget who you are
you know you didn't imprint but if you
wear the same dress he'll remember you
just make sure that every time you go in
wear a different dress so i had to
actually get quite a wardrobe different
dresses it's a theme we seem to be
returning to it's basically like you
know some kind of camouflage you know
it's like i'll wear my jungle camouflage
today or my forest camouflage or my snow
camouflage it's just so that you know i
could just get in there try to do my job
and get out again and i'm presuming this
was different to to working under obama
yeah i mean nobody ever kind of went but
you know that was the sort of theme then
when i get to the impeachment as well
nobody there you know gave me a dress
code actually i looked back in some of
the pictures there thought what the heck
was i wearing but anyway
i just i found it actually quite funny
because it's it was almost like being in
you know some endless school play where
you've got the various costumes and i
guess i was just trying to be a tree you
know kind of when i got into the oval
office just so that nothing untoward
would happen i'm not imagining you yeah
i know exactly the tree thing you know
the kid in the tree hey mom hey dad i'm
a tree well i'm just in the corner in
the oval yeah exactly potted plant
potted plants i've not been in them but
there are no trees in the oval they're
usually outside in the rose garden but
the whole point of all that was you know
get in there without any incident but
really focus on engaging with the other
counterparts i never got treated like
that by the national security team or
the national security advisor it was
just this weird you know coterie around
and it was weird it was like being an
alice in wonderland as well i know so
many analogies i do feel that you know
strange things in my childhood like
reading alice in wonderland alice
through the looking glass and other
things prepared me better than all of
the years of fancy educations and
degrees although it was very important
obviously no rush would know your stuff
but for those moments that wasn't the
best preparation and it isn't a past
some point from your point of view this
was the administration you would have
worked for any administration your point
is you wanted to bring your expertise
but this was how you found this
particular administration yeah and you
mentioned that education it's a key part
of what you've written about your
journey from the coal houses you put it
to the white house and worryingly in
your journey which you you know there
are there are lots of bits of luck as
well you know the particular time you
were born the education that was then
available you really talk about the fact
you don't think it's getting better in
fact it's getting worse that social
mobility
not just in the uk you've looked at it
through the prism of the us as well
is worse
it is it's got much worse over time
exactly right i mean the kind of
opportunities that i had including in
the uk for basically having my education
going to university paid for i mean
those have all shrunk there's just a lot
less funding out there i mean there's
been expansion of places but a lot less
funding for people and just that threat
of enormous debt is really too much for
people um you know thinking and
contemplating that in the united states
you know what you think is the land of
opportunity anyone can make it there's
only a five percent chance now
very different from what it was in the
late 1980s to do what i've done in terms
of going from the bottom one percent to
the top one percent kind of thing and
everybody should have an opportunity you
know to be able to move forward um in
life it doesn't have to be an elite
education but you know to get the kind
of job that they want to get the
qualifications that they need as well
and we need to really think about that i
mean there's been a lot of
movement forward on socioeconomic
background on race and on gender
class to some degree here in the uk i
mean in the united states class gets
subsumed by race in many contexts but in
terms of regional differentiation that's
not the case i mean i still see a huge
divide in the united kingdom between
north and south i've just been up north
to see
you know my mother and family and
friends and it just seems like you know
london is a total world department it's
the same you know for people in
different boroughs in london you know
the city could be no more different from
tower hamlets and things like this for
example
and in the united states is very similar
as well people from you know what we now
call the rust ball we used to be the old
industrial heartlands of the united
states feel that they might live as well
live on another planet as have these
affiliations and affinities with
washington dc that's why january 6
happened it's why people storm the
capital you know that the capital the
white house is the people's house you
know supposed to be the people's house
but the capital is supposed to be their
symbol of representative democracy and
yet people saw it
as a citadel a kind of a forbidding
fortress that wasn't representing them
anymore and just this kind of you know
this upsurge in this insurgency you know
i watched that i thought oh my god you
know look where we've got to here that's
the kind of epitome of these kinds of
problems when people feel that they're
excluded in some way and that sense of
representation is broken down and you
talk in some detail about some of the
things you think need to change at the
heart of education but also what others
can do when they do have positions of
power and influence i've got to ask what
does your mum make of your journey well
i think she's a bit bemused by it she's
pretty pleased at the same time but it's
funny like she took it all in a stride
you know talk in the book about you know
when i was out looking for that suit
that i wore at the impeachment my mom's
just you know sees the sales rack and
sees this suit and she's fiona come over
here look there's a suit for sale do you
need it for that impeachment thingy you
know she didn't even you know kind of
really connect about you know what it
was and she just thought was a great
thing that i you know went there and
told the truth and you know did my job
she wasn't passing you know the big
historical implications of that she just
saw you know my mom's a very practical
person a former midwife
you know if a baby needed delivering in
you know some difficult circumstances
off she would go and just do it without
thinking about all the larger context
she'll just get on with it well you seem
to have adopted a similar style thank
you very much for talking to me and to
all of us today well thanks so much for
having me emma thank you and thank you
to you for being with us until we meet
again take care and goodbye
[Music]
you